[Musik]
für seine anhänger ist ein aufklärer ein
stachel im fleisch eines korrupten
systems seine gegner sagen er zerstört
die demokratie weil er sich über sie
lächerlich macht martin sonneborn ist
der vorsitzende der partei die partei
und seit fünf jahren abgeordneter im
europäischen parlament herzlich
willkommen bei 46 vielen dank guten tag
draußen an den geräten vielen dank dass
sie den ja eigentlich unsere juristen
vertreter der europäischen
parlamentarier ja eingeladen haben und
kann sich auszudrücken kriegen kaffee
können wir ihnen anbieten wasser latte
macchiato blendet virtuose bestes die
kollegen schaue ich schließe mich an kam
es gleich in welcher form auch immer
champagner geht natürlich auch wir sind
hier im herzen europas in brüssel
in der sogenannten station rob das ist
ein ehemaliger bahnhof das hier war der
persönliche warteraum des belgischen
königs leopold der zweite war noch gibt
es nicht mehr dafür jetzt ein raum
innerhalb der gebäude des europäischen
parlaments
wie sehen sie denn ihre rolle hier in
brüssel pausenclown husten aufklärer
ich würde sagen ich bin politiker
ich arbeite zwar mit sagen wir
untypischen mitteln hier
ich habe mein handwerk bei titanic
gelernt einem satiremagazin und die
arbeiter ein bisschen anders als die
kollegen aber im prinzip bin ich
politiker hacker unter des europäischen
parlaments das ist meine
berufsbezeichnung der zeit
sie sind mit slogans angetreten für
europa erreicht für europa gegen europa
was wollen sie denn jetzt europa retten
oder die eu zerstören
der slogan ja zu europa nein zu europa
bezieht sich eigentlich darauf mit dem
sind in der ersten
europawahl 2014 angetreten dass sie
wussten dass 70 prozent der deutschen
der deutschen wähler diese wahl komplett
am arsch vorbeigeht und wir haben
gedacht das sind die 70 prozent die wir
abfischen wollen die uns wählen sollen
deswegen der slogan ja zu europa europa
egal ob sie dafür oder dagegen sind sie
können uns bedenkenlos ihre stimme an
vertrauen und wir machen dann irgendwas
damit so ganz unerfolgreich ist es ja
gar nicht 2,4 prozent jetzt bei der
letzten wahl hat immerhin für zwei
abgeordnete gereicht viermal so viel wie
beim letzten mal
apropos dass das letzte mal beim letzten
mal sind sie angetreten haben gesagt
nach einem monat 30 wieder ab und dann
rotieren wir jeden monaten neun
abgeordneten nach brüssel ist nichts
draus geworden im gegenteil sie sind
jetzt schon in der zweiten
legislaturperiode hier wie das ja ich
habe das zu vollmundig angekündigt dass
wir durch rotieren wollen um 60
parteifreunden mal die möglichkeit geben
wollen hier gut dotierte sich die stadt
brüssel anzuschauen und das parlament
der parteienrechtler von arnim ist mir
dann da reingegrätscht und hat in einer
ganzseitigen in einem artikel in der
liga champion erklärt dass das nicht
funktioniert und dass das parlament und
es einfach das mandat entziehen kann
bedachte einer einfachen abstimmung im
plenarsaal und da haben wir derzeit
keine mehrheiten und insofern war ich
gezwungen hier zu bleiben
tut das aber auch nicht ungern also ich
habe spaß gefunden hier daran politik zu
machen in diesem parlament und kann mir
das auch noch vier jahre vorstellen
er war jetzt eine relativ lange
erklärung dafür dass sie am ende nicht
gelacht haben was sie vorher versprochen
das ist normal in der politik und ich
glaube nicht dass ich deswegen niemand
imports draußen
wir schauen uns jetzt mal an wie sie
politik machen in straßburg einen
kleinen ausschnitt vorbereitet martin
sonneborn im europäischen parlament rede
zur lage der eu
das wort hat jetzt der fraktionslose
abgeordnete sonneborn in vielen dank
chef
die eu hat sich verändert als ich mein
mandat antrat wollte ich für ein starkes
kerneuropa kämpfen mit 27 satelliten
starten
diese anzahl hat sich nun reduziert
nachdem rexit und dem anstehenden
ausschluss der ungarn möchte ich dafür
werben auch den iren die tür zu zeigen
eine regierung die es ablehnt
steuerzahlungen der firma apple am
zunehmen könnte den eindruck erwecken es
gehe um ein europa der konzerne und
nicht der bürger deswegen appelliere ich
an die irische regierung die mister
president of ireland review still
believe that apple will create jobs in
ireland forget it apple only at wann
jobs matthias that he will not come back
to please take my eyes take the money
and run wird in belgien euro will bei
humanic iphones will generate mord kam
vor all and then you can't even more
iphones rc win win win situation
think it over wie sie gut bottle of
whiskey und tee eine kleine bitte noch
herr junker könnten sie ihren digital
kommissar oettinger bitte dazu
verdonnern sich mit seinem handy alle 90
minuten ins deutsche festnetz
einzuloggen
das würde die verhandlungen über roaming
und über leistungsschutzrecht in brüssel
deutlich aufwerten vielen dank herrlich
ist englisch an dem tisch haben sie sich
als sehr lange gearbeitet interesse
erinnert ein bisschen an oettinger
das stimmt ich habe einen alten pennäler
trick angewandt ich habe meine
mundwinkel nach hinten und nach oben
gezogen um es so ein bisschen länger
haften englisch zu sprechen
das hat ja auch er habe ich den eindruck
einen ernsthaften kern ist lustig aber
hat einen ernsthaften kern denn sie
sprechen eine sache an die in der tat
ein problem ist nämlich die mangelhafte
besteuerung amerikanische digital
konzern in der europäischen union
was stört sie am steuerrecht in europa
ja ganz einfach dass ich viel mehr
steuern zahlen als zum beispiel der
konzern apple über sind ja dass die in
irland das gesamte europageschäft
besteuern und bei einem steuersatz was
ich für sie versteuern aber 0,005
prozent das ist relativ optimiert das
ist nahezu optimal
und was mich an bord hat ist dass dieses
geld nicht mehr eingetrieben worden das
sind irland da haben sich zwölf oder 14
milliarden angesammelt und die könnte
man ja jetzt vielleicht nicht hier aber
in deutschland gut gebrauchen
täuscht das oder haben sie ihren stil
geändert mehr inhalt und und weniger
klamauk als vorher
ich bemühe mich natürlich den stil
weiter beizubehalten aber es ist in der
tat so dass mit dass klamauk machen
manchmal etwas schwer fällt wenn ich
sehe die neuen entwicklungen jetzt sogar
von der leyen die kommission aufstellung
die kommissare die aus den ländern
geschickt werden
ich arbeite wie sie auch gerade gehört
haben an der verkleinerung der eu weil
ich so liberale staaten wie ungarn und
polen gerne raus schmeißen würde
korrupte staaten wie bulgarien und
rumänien dann so steueroasen wie irland
luxemburg deutschland
also es ist einiges zu tun geht die
sonne bahn ohne klamauk überhaupt wenn
ich will dich nicht zu nahe treten aber
wenn ich ernsthafte politische arbeit in
brüssel will an keiner auch grüne oder
spd oder cdu wählen sie kriegen nein
also ich habe spaß daran natürlich mit
den methoden
die mir spaß machen seit titanic zeiten
zu arbeiten und das hat den vorteil ich
bin kein freund ausgewiesener sacharbeit
das für dich langweilig es hat den
vorteil dass unsere sachen relativ große
öffentlichkeit erreichen wenn man eine
kritik mit einem witz verpacken kann
dann verbreitet er sich einfach und dann
kann man darüber wiederum auch politik
machen jetzt nicht hier bei phoenix mit
ihren einschaltquoten aber im internet
zum beispiel
vielen dank für die blumen wird ja aber
wir hoffen auf ein bisschen was wie
sieht denn ihr alltag so in brüssel aus
rät die anderen abgeordneten mit ihnen
oder schneiden diese weise einen
nestbeschmutzer sind das ist sehr
unterschiedlich also ich habe wenig
freunde unter den konservativen
abgeordneten das können sie sich
vorstellen
es gibt natürlich also jüngere
abgeordnete sagen wir mal so souveräne
abgeordnete die kein problem haben mit
mir umzugehen mit denen tausche ich mich
aus es gibt kontakte natürlich in erst
zu den grünen und zu den linken
und ja noch nicht zu den konservativen
mein lieblings politiker m a broken 179
kilogramm konzentrierte cdu ist ja jetzt
überraschend nach knapp 40 jahren nicht
mehr aufgestellt worden von seiner
partei das war eigentlich der mann ich
habe drei aufgaben gestellt dass ich
hier anfing dass eine wahrheit ein
bisschen transparenz öffentlichkeit
herstellen für das für die unseriösen
seiten der europäischen union die
seriösen werden ja von für nächsten
anderen sendern transportiert das zweite
war dass ich ab und zu politische
diskussion politische positionen
durchblicken lasse in großen reden die
ich vor meist leeren plenarsaal schwinge
und das dritte war dicke alte weiße
männer zu ärgern die die eu in diese
situation gebracht haben in dieser krise
und der sie jetzt ist und da war immer
brocken ein gutes ein gutes porto
die sind ja nicht der einzige
außenseiter im europäischen parlament da
ist ja eine bunte truppe polnische
monarchisten nachfolger der iaa aus zehn
fällen aus
aus nordirland und irland und
rechtspopulisten jeder couleur gibt es
da so eine art schicksalsgemeinschaft
der freaks im europaparlament
das eben sie gar nicht mit denen nein
das selten gibt leute denen ich nicht
spreche jungen leuten hat mich kurz mal
angesprochen von der perfekten hfd ich
bin eigentlich vernünftig und grüße auch
nicht ich hatte einfach mal nein da dass
ihre wortwahl ist ihre wortwahl aber die
sind nicht da könnte ich habe mich
mobilität sofern ich hoffe man hat mich
damals angesprochen kürzlich werden
einen ein poster mit ihm veröffentlicht
hat sich der ortsverein karlsruhe der
partei extra noch entschuldigt
wir hatten zum politischen
aschermittwoch so ein bild gepostet und
darüber politischer aschermittwoch
geschrieben er dachte sich bei mir
beschwert dass man mir unangenehm weil
ich da tatsächlich mit ihnen
kommunizieren musste es gibt eigentlich
hatte sich entschuldigte für oder
fernseher posco hat mich gefragt ob ich
das die los finden würde ich hab gesagt
seine gesamte partei sei auch wesentlich
stillose es gibt extrem unsere user
gestalten im europäischen handel stock
damit die haben auch nicht kommuniziert
ist dass das in die hand genommen aber
wenn sie jetzt so ein spiel okay finden
also sie denn jetzt einen politischen
gegner mit am mittwoch eröffnen sich
doch alle schleusen mit welchem recht
wollen sie dann noch einen zb rechten
abgeordneten vorwerfen wenn die dann
ihrerseits hetzen beleidigen sie haben
doch dann alle grenzen gesprengt
der ortsverein der partei karlsruhe hat
sich ein schuldig dafür dass da ein
rechtschreibfehler stattgefunden habe
auf diesem plakat insofern
da sind wir da glaube ich auf der
sicheren seite aber ich glaube es ist
ein unterschied ob man wir versuchen
seit titanic zeiten politik zu
kritisieren aus einer moralischen
position heraus und es ist glaube ich
ein unterschied ob man dazu solche
methoden greift oder ob man
rechtsradikaler ist und dann anfängt die
politischen gegner zu beschimpfen ich
würde auch noch zurückweisen
das ist zb hf dealer in der
öffentlichkeit im internet dann
beleidigungen aus bringen und dann
hinter bauten der satire gewesen was man
schreiben sie es noch mit de das ist
natürlich unfug wenn wir mal weiter über
den alltag im europäischen parlament sie
haben sich keine fraktion daten
geschlossen waren sie nicht
ich hätte mich fast der grünen fraktion
angeschlossen das war nämlich so dass
jörg leuten von der hfg vollmundig
erklärt hat dass sie eine starke rechte
fraktion im parlament
zusammen stellen würden und dann bis auf
lediglich 73 mandatsträger gekommen und
die grüne fraktion hatte auch 73 jetzt
sind die an uns herangetreten und niko
semlitsch unserem zweiten mann und mich
haben gefragt ob wir ihnen beitreten
nico ist an beigetreten so hatten die 74
und sind stärkere fraktion als die
rechtsradikalen geworden das ist wichtig
im parlament und wenn es jetzt noch ein
rechtsradikaler mehr gewesen wäre dann
hätte ich mir das auch überlegt aber als
fraktionsloser muss ich mich weniger
rechtfertigen und ich bekommen auch mehr
redezeit
da gibt es ja wahren abstimmungsmarathon
im europäischen parlament was weiß ich
dutzende von von abstimmungen innerhalb
weniger minuten
wie stimmen sie denn da ab ohne die
fraktion die in sagte ob sie dafür oder
dagegen stemmen sollen
ich habe das früher so gelöst indem ich
einfach abwechselnd mit ja und nein
gestimmt habe die meisten abgeordneten
oder fast alle wissen nicht worum es
geht bei dieser abstimmung und
orientieren sich da so an listen ich
habe aber auch gesehen dass neben mir so
ein fieser fpd ein rechtsradikaler aus
der steiermark mit seinem dicken daumen
der liste verrutscht ist und dann
permanent gegen seine interessen
gestimmt hat ich habe gesehen wie eine
spd dame aufstand und gesagt hat
entschuldigen sie herr präsident wir
müssen die letzte abstimmung wiederholen
die komplette deutsche sozialdemokratie
hat sich verstimmt wir sind natürlich
für menschenrechte
also erst dann wiederholt worden oder
das ist wiederholt worden aber ich
wollte darauf hinaus dass eine einzelne
stimme
zumal wir hatten in der letzten
legislaturperiode eine groko haram aus
spd und cdu eine große koalition
die ich hier alles durchsetzen konnte
und da war es egal der mann daran ja
sportbranche sport eigentlich für die
unfähige große koalition die wir in
deutschland haben und die da genauso
viel unheil anrichtet wie im
europäischen parlament und ihre
zwischenfrage hat mich aus dem konzept
gebracht worden ich würde darauf aus
dass sie erklären wie sie abstimmen
ja nein und jetzt machen wir noch
öffentliche hand also bei 114 150
stimmen abstand ist es vollkommen egal
wie ich abstimme und bei knappen
abstimmung bin ich informiert worden und
werde auch informiert von linken grünen
oder sozialdemokraten und da lege ich
dann meine stimme schon sehr gezielt ich
habe auch schon abstimmungen entschieden
im september erreichte der europa
ich habe mehr erreicht als je hätte
erreichen können ich habe eine
datenschutz verordnung mit abgestimmt
und habe die entscheidende stimme
geliefert die privacy heißt die die
kennen sie nicht weil die
zeitungsverlage nicht darüber berichten
weil die zeitungsverleger der eigene
interessen
wir ziehen und diese
datenschutzbestimmungen kümmert sich zum
beispiel darum dass ihre
messenger-dienste wenn sie die benutzten
bob sap zum beispiel konnten sie kennen
wenn sie mit ihren kindern kommunizieren
dass das nicht komplett ausgelesen
analysiert ausgewertet und verkauft
werden darf es gibt ja momentan keine
rechtliche bestimmung weil die gesetze
noch aus zeiten zurück in denen es
lediglich sms gab und das ist also
durchs parlament gegangen diese app ist
die verordnung und sie wird jetzt nur
noch vom rat blockiert
der rat das muss man zusammen sind die
arschlöcher in europa es gibt drei
institutionen das ist das gewählte
demokratisch gewählte parlament das
kranke nur daran dass ist kein
initiativrecht hat in einer demokratie
geht so was nicht
die kommission sind technokraten die
kann man steuern politisch und der rate
sind die 28 regierungschefs und die
entscheiden man sieht dass gerade wieder
absolut im nationalen interesse und das
muss man kritisieren sie sitzt
wahrscheinlich nichts wenn ich sie bitte
leute die nicht da sehen und sich nicht
wehren können dann nicht zu beleidigen
dass sein fernseher sitzen
dann würden sie sich zumindest freuen
gut wie schluss vergeben sie denn hier
als europa körper mehr als sie hoffe ich
habe ich habe ein buch geschrieben ich
habe alles aufgeschrieben was ich hier
gesehen habe und was ich hier an
lustigen dinge erlebt habe und was ich
zu kritisieren habe da ist natürlich
auch die höhe des gehalts oder dass der
diät drin
ich weiß nur dass ich 6300 irgendwas
ausgezahlt bekomme aber die sendezeit
würde vermutlich nicht reichen um die
weiteren vergünstigungen die mir zu
stehen
wir haben das schon mal auf addiert mit
mitarbeiter pauschale und europa schale
und talkurs keller sind sie auf über
30.000 euro gekommen wir nennen es habt
33 weil es über 33.000 euro sind aber
sie dürfen jetzt nicht den eindruck
verbreiten dass ich mir zum beispiel die
mitarbeiter pauschale 1 stecken könnte
ich habe assistenten die auch geld haben
wollen und das läuft über zahlstellen
seitdem die osteuropäer in der eu sind
hat man da sehr viele
sicherungsmaßnahmen eingebaut und da
kommt man nicht mehr so einfach
leider wir schauen uns nochmal eine rede
von eden europaparlament angesehen
anlässlich des besuchs von angela merkel
vielen dank präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin ich muss mich
entschuldigen
ich habe gar keine rede vorbereitet ich
habe die rede die zeit nur beantragt
weil sie sonst den duft von der npd
gefallen wäre und ich moment lassen sie
mich ausreden und ich verachte
kleinparteien unter ein prozent unserer
user kleinparteien unter 1 prozent
insofern möchte ich gar nicht viel sagen
wir haben haben es zum letzten mal
gesehen hier beim abschied von helmut
kohl jetzt sehen wir uns bei ihrem
abschied ich möchte ihnen auf dem weg
geben sie werden mir immer sympathischer
je mehr ich leute sehe die ihnen in der
cdu folgen werden in den nächsten
monaten und jahren
ich möchte sie bitten wenn sie gehen
übergeben sie unser land besenrein das
wäre nett und jetzt können sie gehen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
sie haben sie denn gegen die cdu was ich
gegen die cdu habe also ganz einfach ich
sitze im europaparlament und sehe vorne
rechts vor mir
das gilt für die letzten fünf jahre
einen großen konservativen block der
praktisch alles weg stimmt mit
mehrheiten was sich für die bürger
einsetzt der finanzdienstleistungs
orientiert und wirtschaftsorientierte
abstimmt der gegen die umwelt abstimmt
der für glyphosat abstimmt das ist mir
extrem unsympathisch und deswegen bin
ich politisch auf der anderen seite ihre
gegner sagen das was sie wachen zerstört
am ende die demokratie zum beispiel
weise abgeordneten die ernsthafte
politische arbeit behandeln wollen den
platz wegnehmen
ein interessantes argument ich weiß gar
nicht wer für mich im parlament sitzen
würde aber es wäre ein hinterbänkler wir
haben sehr viele hinterbänkler wir haben
sehr viele einfache leute auch jüngere
abgeordnete im parlament gerade in den
konservativen parteien
ich glaube nicht dass die eine bessere
politik eine für die bürger engagierte
politik machen würden als ich das tun
ich hab mir mal ein zitat von einer spd
abgeordneten kerstin westphal war zehn
jahre lang im europäischen kontinent sie
sagte ihre patente bei uns ihre eu
satire sei genauso gefährlich wie die
kampagnen der rechtspopulisten weil sie
versuchen die eu von innen zu zerstören
indem sie sie lächerlich macht das in
der analyse ich habe die damen glaube
ich entlassen lassen ist nicht mehr im
europäischen parlament nämlich recht
erinnere sich laura gewählt worden ist
vielen spd sich abgeordneten sowie ja zu
recht
es ist in der tat nicht so dass ich die
europäische parlament terry hier
zerstören möchte das konstrukt ist in
ordnung ist nur mit den falschen leuten
besetzt wir haben zu viele abgeordnete
die nicht im sinne der bürger abstimmen
und deswegen ist auch eine aufgabe die
wir uns gestellt haben
öffentlichkeit herzustellen die
abgeordneten des europäischen
parlamentes beklagen sich immer darüber
dass sie nicht wahrgenommen werden in
deutschland so war quatsch wenn wir mal
zb artikel 13 wenn wir mal
abstimmungsergebnisse visualisieren und
einfach ins netz stellen wer von cdu und
spd wie abgestimmt hat dann gibt es
hinterher entführungen und anrufe bei
den grünen war es auch so dass lena
plötzlich sehen wie ihre abgeordneten
hier für sie abstimmen und da gab es da
ist einiges an unmut in einigen
aufgekommen was kann man denn überhaupt
mit mit den mitteln von satire ironie
zynismus erreichen
also ich glaube man kann zwei dinge tun
man kann erstens öffentlichkeit
herstellen für das was in die
öffentlichkeit gehört meines erachtens
und zweitens ist satire
es ist eine reaktion auf dinge die uns
umgibt und belastet und diesem zunehmend
enger werdenden kapitalistischen system
hilft ist wenn sie einen guten witz über
dinge machen können die sie vielleicht
nicht ändern können aber diese störung
können sie die einstellung von menschen
ändern
ich glaube dass wir haben relativ viele
junge leute die uns folgen und dass wir
auch eine gewisse interpretationshoheit
über dinge aus dem europäischen
parlament haben ihm bei jungen wählern
die ehemaligen volksparteien haben ja
mehr so letzt wähler publikum und wir
haben bei den europawahlen festgestellt
dass wir bei den erstwählern die
drittstärkste partei waren in berlin
haben wir 48 prozent gehabt jetzt
europaweit haben wir vor der fdp ich
glaube schon dass man moralische
standpunkte verankern kann und dass man
eine gewisse orientierung bieten kann
junge ist es auch ein effekt dass sie
menschen für europa sagen wir mal nicht
nicht begeistert aber zumindest
interessieren die sich ansonsten für
politik überhaupt nicht interessiert
wird dieser vorwurf wird mir immer
wieder gemacht und zudem stehe ich ja
im prinzip machen wir das gleiche sie ja
eigentlich sind wir phoenix im
europaparlament
wir geben teilweise unkommentiert heraus
was wir in europa passiert sie berichten
also reagiert zumindest wie von phoenix
wir glauben an mündige bürger die sich
selber und teil machen worden könnte ja
sein dass sie ähnliche richtung wie
arbeit nehmen beschimpfen
was wir jetzt allerdings nicht machen
ist sowas wie sie bei der aufstellung
ihrer liste zur bundestagswahl haben sie
ganz bewusst auf den folgenden plätzen
dann menschen ausgewählt die hatten dann
so illustre namen wie göring und tom
reichmann keitel habe wie sie viele
menschen haben gesagt so was ist es
geschmacklos ja wir haben das ist
tatsächlich geschmacklos habe nämlich
noch einen goebbels mit öl gefunden und
nicht mit oe sind alle parteimitglieder
wir haben die aufgestellt um auf die
remilitarisierung der eu hinzuweisen und
um verwirrte fdp-wähler abzufischen die
ersten zehn namen standen auf den
wahlzetteln unten fdp wähler und der
geringen eigenanteil hess sieht ist
natürlich da mitunter auch versucht sein
kreuz bei uns zu machen aber es gibt
eine eine wahnsinnige militarisierung
die werden in der letzten
legislaturperiode beobachtet haben ich
habe selber einen eu haushalt mit
abgestimmt für die nächsten sieben jahre
in dem zum ersten mal mehr gelder für
aufrüstung grenzsicherung und
militarisierung vorhandenes als für
entwicklungshilfe und das ist natürlich
wahnsinn diese zeiten und es geht weiter
mit frau von der leyen ist ja eine
kommissionspräsidentin jetzt installiert
worden keine der gewählten
spitzenkandidaten ist aufgestellt worden
das muss man immer wieder kritisieren
sondern eine frau die im
verteidigungsressort schon einiges an
unheil angerichtet hat und die mit makro
zusammen milliardenschwere 40 projekte
angeschoben hat die werden sich da gut
verstehen und wir werden weiter
aufrüsten obwohl der vertrag von
lissabon ist der eu untersagt gelder in
militärisch projekte zu stecken
seit fünf jahren sind sie jetzt im
europäischen parlament eben laufe der
zeit ist ihnen da die
europäische union sympathischer geworden
ans herz gewachsen oder ist das ein
monster das nie was wird dass das
resümee nach fünf jahren war tatsächlich
das konstrukt funktioniert aber es ist
mit den falschen leuten besetzt die
leute sicher die leute die da ins
europaparlament gewählt werden das sind
die leute die die bürger sich gewählt
haben immer ihre abgeraten haben derart
leider auch die 28 regierungschefs wir
bräuchten eine jüngere eine linke eine
grünere davos noch sozialdemokratie in
reston gibt eine sozialdemokratische
lösung und solange es diese
wahlergebnisse nicht gibt
die wahlergebnisse können sie ja nun nur
noch begrenzt ändern weil die bürger
wählen wie sie welt was würden sie denn
sonst tun um europa voranzubringen
also ich denke wir können der
öffentlichkeit herstellen und einfach
zeigen wie konservativ in europa regiert
wird und dass das ist das einzige was
wir machen können wenn die leute sich
dann entscheiden anders zu wählen dann
freut mich das aber ich habe nicht den
anspruch dass ich jetzt den kontinent
rette ich finde es nur ein bisschen
schade dass zum teil die seriöseste
kritik von unseriösen typen wie nie ihr
oder wir uns jetzt kommt und das ja das
ist hier so große konservative kreise
gibt
die eigentlich nicht mehr kompetent
kritisiert werden im prinzip steigen die
chancen für ihre partei die partei weil
spd und cdu die volksparteien zu legen
sich ist ja jede menge stimmen auf dem
feld es gibt auch eine biologische seite
bei den wahlen also viel letzt wähler
sind ja dann auch irgendwann aus dem
rennen und da wir die erstwähler
motivieren können an die wahlurnen zu
gehen sehe ich da eigentlich dass wir
führende mathematiker in der partei
haben ausgerechnet wir verdoppeln unsere
wahlergebnisse zurzeit wenn wir zum
zweiten und zum dritten mal auf
wahlzetteln auftauchen dass wir noch 64
weitere bundestags verein brauchen
bisher an der macht sind in deutschland
nur noch zwei drei sätze zu ihnen
persönlich wann haben sie denn den
spaßvogel in sich selber entdeckt vielen
dank für diese frage was ganz eigenen
moderatorin sich entdeckt ich mache das
eine ganze weile in der schule an den
tisch waren sich schon der spaßvogel der
klassen plan in der schule
ich glaube schon dass ich in situationen
in denen ich im geschichtsunterricht
nicht mit fakten aufwarten konnte
versucht habe lustige bemerkungen zu
machen
leider wir einen sehr alten
geschichtslehrer der das nicht goutiert
ich glaube das ist ja eine frühkindliche
prägung vermutlich jetzt haben die
parlamentarische immunität
da können sich einiges erlauben am segen
haben sie vorbilder dieter hildebrandt
karl valentin sowas
nein es gibt natürlich
orientierungspunkte also ich bin von
titanic sozialisiert oder mit titanic
sozialisiert worden und mit monty python
in großbritannien das ist der mann der
mir gefällt und vorbilder würde ich
meinem alter nicht mehr haben sie noch
vorbilder hatte ich eigentlich nie er so
ist hat mir meinen eigenen weg gesucht
aber ich bin jetzt ja auch nicht so auf
einer schiene unterwegs wie sie beim
humor jedoch klar
die taz hat mich mal als den was
taktiken der deutschen politik
bezeichnet
das finde ich eigentlich gute einstufung
wie sind sie denn zu hause sind
verheiratet hatte zwei kinder sind sie
da auch ironisch bissig zynisch oder
sind sie privat ganz anders das würde
mir meine familie niemals erlauben
ich war schon da sagt weis tätig zu sein
oder aber das sei er ohne zu sagen da
kriege ich sofort ausbauen kann man
kindern und ich glaube dass also die
sagen wir mal die öffentliche person und
die private person ist weitgehend
deckungsgleich aber nicht alles was ich
mir im parlament erlaubt würde ich noch
zu hause genommen
wie geht es denn jetzt weiter bleiben
sie satiriker oder lieb eignet sich
damit ins ernsthafte politische fach zu
wechseln
vielen dank für das angebot aber ich
glaube das kann nicht ablehnen ich habe
absolut kein interesse an sacharbeit
oder ein seriöser politik ich glaube das
ist erfolgreich was wir machen und das
will ich auch weiter tun
das war phoenix persönlich halte er mit
martin sonneborn herzlichen dank vielen
dank für den kaffee und schuss draußen
an den geräten
[Musik]